[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
we leave civilization behind us and go
into the heartland of the mountains
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to build the nests may take up to five
minutes carefully selected vines and
stalks are been in around the animal's
body to make a good rim the younger
animals seem to have a bit of trouble
with foliage that seems to have a mind
of its own therefore it has to be put in
place bodily they begin plainest at the
age of two years but sometimes their
initial flimsy efforts need more
practice
[Music]
perhaps because he has lost all of his
peers or maybe because he is in that
special classification of young males
digit has been remarkably of tolerant
toward observers and even appears to
welcomed their presence
he is also especially attracted to
objects we take out into the field such
as camera lenses notebooks and gloves
slowly slowly over the years about a
year and a half all the animals of group
four were approaching very closely
simply because of their own initiative
and the sense of curiosity
to have finally been accepted by the
wild gorillas was its own reward and the
thrill of each day's contact is one that
will never diminish
[Music]